attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant moi
cinquante ans vous les faites bien quand
même ah non non non tu fais plus oui
mais si j'avais moins picollec rémois
taper en tout cas ça me fait vraiment
plaisir de vous avoir avec moi
aujourd'hui
bon je pensais pas que mon jour ne
serait un beauf mais ça me fait plaisir
quand même tu as pris récemment
d'ailleurs qu'on pouvait voir à quoi
allait ressembler sa femme en regardant
sa mère et comment je pourrais toujours
et ça me rassure parce que sinon je te
récusé tout de suite en tout cas 50 ans
tu as fait le plus gros seins
voici le meilleur est derrière vraiment
je les anniversaires
zumbox quand j'avais pas d'idée partir à
l'aventuré la découverte de nouvelles
sensations et à quoi là dedans et safari
en afrique un tricot perron banon ça m'a
coûté trente balles non mais regarde y'a
peut-être de l'accrobranche à melun
encore une merde qui va rester dans le
placard je l'utiliserai jamais le rouge
assez bien joli collier de princesse
merci ma chérie j'adore c'est à mo'nique
qui me l'a offert un âne derniers mois
j'ai jamais vu puisque je trouve ça
dégueulasse un truc de vieilles recettes
ira bien donc ça très bien côté manon
sacs icool haut et les fleurs c'est toi
mon chéri complètement oublié du coup il
y avait plus que fleuriste d'ouvert mais
j'étais plus aussi le dernier livre de
jean marc levy je les commander sur
internet tu le rates en deux jours le
dernier la leur os ccc de ma part c'est
ces deux mois ce qu'est ce que c'est que
ça c'est qu'elle est et on a jamais
offert à votre fille ella qui fait du
coup je me suis dit telle mère telle
fille d'aller voir pour avaler m ce soir
quand ça tourne à ses énormes beau-papa
ce soir c'est clair mais ce
[Musique]